good morning John it's Sunday July 27th
[Music]
the mall shopping for glasses as you can
probably tell so yesterday I was tubing
on the Clark Fork River and I lost my
glasses I gave them to the Clark Fork
asalaam offering of my appreciation for
it beauty and awesomeness it didn't give
them back so now I'm here looking for
new glasses it's why I've decided that
today I'm going to do two things at the
glasses store one I'm going to request
that the nerdfighters helped me pick out
a new pair of glasses and none of the
ones you've seen so far are in the
rankings so don't mention these and two
the new little experiment on how to get
glasses for cheap and hopefully by the
end of the process they'll all know how
to get cheap cheap dttp classes because
glasses are very expensive and I don't
know if they're worth it because most of
them they're just like hunks of plastic
generally you want to start out with
just a little bit browsing just browse
find what you like
put them on try them on if you want to
take pictures and send them to your mom
or your boyfriend or your girlfriend or
the Pope and make sure that they like
them and are appreciative and will enjoy
you and your new glasses and when you
find something you like you want to
write down the little serial number and
all the numbers below the serial number
and the price as well of course to make
sure that you're getting a better to
your long line than you would at the
store and then you say toodaloo to the
entire mall experience and you never
ever ever ever ah ever buy glasses in a
brick-and-mortar store because the
markup is like at least a hundred
percent so when they tell you 25 percent
off that generally means maybe we're
gonna charge you a little bit less than
twice as much as we paid for the glasses
and you know it's a business so they can
do what they want to do but if we can
get a better deal online we should get a
better deal online the ones you get home
just take that serial number type it in
and find that on Amazon or a dozens of
other sites you can get them for
hundreds of dollars cheaper now there's
two ways to do this can buy your glasses
entirely online you should only do that
if you know a few things first you need
to know the distance your pupils are
apart and second you need a recent
prescription you don't have those things
and you need to go to the store and get
them to make the lenses for you the good
news for me is that there's a really
great place in downtown Missoula it's
like a family owned an operated store
and they'll make lenses for any frame
really really cheap so what I'm gonna do
is buy the frames online and then visit
my friend downtown and she'll make the
lenses she'll also make any adjustments
necessary to make
to set my head and she'll do that
totally for free but I'm going to need
your help figuring out which classes to
buy is it John John I know that you guys
like my old glasses and you probably are
going to be devastated that I had to get
new ones I'm totally gonna have to
redraw the cartoon me to put the new
glasses on it so John and nerdfighters
and anyone else who is watching this
video right now you are invited to vote
on which glasses I should buy and wear
for the next like five years of my life
so don't screw it up for me so without
further ado here are your choices
forehead grins glasses of the future one
two three four five six oh seven have
you want to see those again I'm gonna
show it after the little thingy comes up
and if you want to want the video over
and over again that's not gonna hurt our
view count so I welcome you to do that
so quick make your decision leave it in
the comments and I'll see you which one
wins and I will order that one
immediately pretty exciting now I'm
gonna go superglue an old pair of
glasses back together to have the wrong
prescription in them so that I can have
something in the meantime that allow me
to see just a little bit John I will see
you soon but not as soon as many
Michigan nerdfighters will see you now
Michigan nerdfighters please bear with
me as I get very close to my computer
screen and read to you the location
where John Green will be speaking
tomorrow flash today if it's Monday
let's get close to the screen to read it
the Spring Lake District Library 2:00
p.m. on Monday July 28th one two three
East exchange Street
bring Lake Michigan
one two three four five six or seven
these gigantic glasses want you to
subscribe